it's obama to the rescue the nation's
44th president getting a rock star
welcome as he returned to the white
house to tout obamacare it was a welcome
sight for the flailing democrats who
were in need of a distraction from the
avalanche of bad news that is the biden
administration
vice president biden
vice president
that was a joke
and joe biden and i did a lot together
we helped save the global economy
made record investments in clean energy
we put guard rails
on our financial system we helped turn
the auto industry around
repeal don't ask don't tell
but nothing
made me prouder
than
providing better health care and more
protections to millions of people across
this country
but wake up democrats you're still stuck
with this guy
my name is joe biden and i'm barack
obama's vice president
our republican colleagues
as they say in southern delaware haven't
changed a whole hell of a lot
good folks but haven't changed a lot
they continue to attack the affordable
care act if republicans have their way
it means 100 million americans with
pre-existing conditions
can once again be denied health care
coverage by their insurance companies so
now
i'm going to sign an executive order
and barack let me remind you
it's a hot mic
it's no wonder they're trotting out a
superstar like obama as biden's horrible
poll numbers spelled doom for the
democrats all right jesse i'll start
with you
uh what can bail out the democrats this
year is a photo op good enough no they
need another coveted wave that's the
only thing that could help their numbers
i don't think this is going to give the
democrats the jolt they're looking for
it just reminds them that joe biden was
nothing more than vice presidential
material this is why people don't like
to take pictures with other people who
are better looking than they are i did a
shoot one time for the factor it was a
polo match in the hamptons and i went
and i interviewed afterwards the head of
the argentinian polo squad his name was
nacho faguero and he was also the face
of ralph lauren for about a decade and
that was a big mistake because my face
was in a profile shot right next to his
face and the camera shot was very tight
and you can really contrast the two of
us physically and i remember dennis
miller appeared after the package ran on
the factor and said put the screen back
up
and he goes on the left you have nacho
and on the right not so much
and it was hurtful but it was true you
don't want to really put two people in a
room like that when it's like being a
boxer sometimes one guy completely
outclasses the other guy and that's what
you saw here with barack and joe biden
it would have been different if you know
you have a bush or a trump or a reagan
in the same room an obama or a clinton
those are two kind of hall of fame guys
right but this is not it this is someone
who
people that work for him
don't want to work for him and that's
why you saw last night yesterday or what
was this a couple hours ago there was
nostalgia and there was a feeling that
they were happy about the past but they
weren't excited about the future and
obama looked like he was rubbing biden's
nose in it a few times like you know
what
i actually signed major legislation in
my first two years
and i think at the end of the day people
went back from that event and felt like
you know what i'm working for a jimmy
carter i remember what it was like when
barack obama was there all right dana
republicans have a 17 point advantage in
terms of enthusiasm the last time that
happened was 12 years ago the democrats
i believe lost 60 seats in the house so
they decide to celebrate the american
uh
the obamacare and the truth is that the
anniversary apparently was a couple of
weeks ago but biden really has very
little to celebrate
well
president obama lost 63 seats in that
first midterm but i think remember i
think that in a way that they just
decided to embrace that and say well it
was worth it um and the politics of
health care have cut both ways so in
2012 they
i'm sorry 2010 they lose 63 seats but in
2018 the democrats were able to get
republicans uh to lose in several seat
districts because they couldn't
republicans failed to replace obamacare
repeal and replace that was what they
promised they couldn't do that and they
filed that stupid lawsuit they never let
it go and in fact it was the one that
amy coney barrett actually she was
getting attacked for but then when it
actually came to the court she went the
way that the
the majority went she she upheld that so
i just feel that 12 years ago it's it's
a fine anniversary event it's not going
to matter i do think that president
obama at least like he he embraced what
he had right and he was a much better
communicator than president biden so
health care it can cut both ways what
the president president biden's issue is
inflation and they didn't talk about
that at all today
all right what about that jessica they
didn't talk about inflation and they now
are saying that president ob president
biden needs to be more visible he needs
to have more photo ops do you think that
that'll make a difference
i think so i think that what's going on
right now with inflation is certainly a
problem that cuts on both sides of the
aisle and you've seen democrats and
independents voicing very similar
concerns to republicans about it but
fundamentally democrats and independents
really like joe biden as a person
they've accepted his quirks that he can
go off message that he can kind of
disappear into a crowd but then he'll
remember your son's name if your son has
stutter and he's written to president
biden about it he's going to be there
and he might even shoot a commercial
with him and having president obama
there is incredibly important surrogate
work which everyone uses on both sides
of the aisle donald trump is appearing
on stages all across the country in
rallies with candidates that are
supporting him that's how it works and
the reason that being there for the
affordable care act is so important as
to dana's point republicans have still
yet to put up a viable alternative and
mitch mcconnell was on a sunday show
this past weekend and he got asked well
what is your plan
if republicans are going to be in
control again and he said we'll wait and
see they haven't released a plan they
didn't do the plan we're just working on
it
oh well it's a great it's going to be
the best is nacho helping out with it
yes um
but that might not be enough coming out
of a global health pandemic to just hear
wait and see on health care they need to
know what you're doing versus democrats
that are expanding health care to
millions more people and that's why
obama is there and should be there every
day
okay but americans greg they understand
that the president is biden
and biden isn't changing the prices at
the gas pump or at the supermarket what
can biden do
you should try not to get lost
right
have you seen this tape i love this it's
him it's just like where'd everybody go
this is kind of more of a symbolic of
how
the presidency is going right now you
have everybody
around obama and then you have joe just
kind of like walking off so sad it is
and about that 17-point enthusia
enthusiasm gap that's so why ted kennedy
could drive a car through it and joe so
underwater you might think he's in that
car
i just wanted to start with that but you
know what here's the thing okay
this next election the voters have to
respond to the way that they've been
treated you have
coveted inequality right masks versus
the unmasks the servitude in masks you
have the marginalization of parents you
have the crime wave but then you have
these other things like the just the
raging mental illness that you're seeing
everywhere you're seeing homelessness
you're seeing education just a mess
what's interesting about all of these
things is this is the left's wheelhouse
we've been told for 40 years right that
they were the people that cared that
republicans only cared about making
money they were country clubbers they
were white they wore khakis but it was
the left they were out there on the
street fighting for the victims and
fighting for people's rights but it
turns out wherever they go the rights
get limited and people die it's not it's
not it it's time this is the real red
pill right the left always claims the
higher ground on education mental health
victims rights uh racial justice class
warfare even with inflation how can
americans not see that they have been
wrong on every single aspect and made
life's life worse i but i am going to be
a soggy blanket on this which dr jill is
all too familiar with it's if it's not a
blowout if it's not 70 seats at a
minimum then the republicans blew it
because there's no better opportunity
than right now to really change the face
of the political landscape and if you
don't do it now then you're probably
never going to do it the only hope is
elon musk
we'll talk about him later but dana you
had i just wanted to say one other thing
if you look at polls consistently this
is what's weird about the democrats
they're not satisfied with obamacare
if you look at any of the polls they'll
consistently say that what is their
their top issues climate change second
issue is healthcare and so they're never
satisfied with it and that's one thing
that the republicans will probably do
which is to say we're not going to go to
socialized medicine
okay hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else